يومان من السجال شغل عالم مواقع التواصل
بين تويتر ومنافسه الجديد القادم من متى
اليوم لم يعد التغريد منفردا في عالم
التواصل فالتثريد صار واقعا لا جدال فيه
خصوصا مع انضمام اسماء كبيره لتسرد لاول
مره عبر تطبيق الجديد
مشاهدينا يسخر من ويرى انه انستجرام بلا
صور كما يصفه في احدى تغريداته لكن خلف
هذه السخريه معركه كبيره عنوانها العريض
هز عرشه تويتر ومالكه ماسك الفعل بين
التثريد والتغريد هناك قصه عميقه ومنافسه
مشتعله بين من كان يمزحان الحقيقه قبل
ايام بخصوص صراع في حلبه
هذه المنافسه يرويها لنا في بوخصيان من
كاليفورنيا حيث بدا مارك ومتى باش عال نار
ماسك وعصفوره الازرق وشوه يمكن
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مراهق غريب الاطوار كان يملك
حسابا على تويتر يغرد ليكشف تحركات طائره
الى ماسك غضب ماسك واوقف حسابه ثم ظهر
الشعب على منصه اخرى وبطبيعه الحال المنصه
الاخرى هي
[موسيقى]
هنا في كاليفورنيا ظهور تطبيق جديد ليس
بالقصه الكبيره كل يوم يولد مشروع تولد
منصه يولد تطبيق لكن المنبثقه من انستجرام
والذي يكاد يكون نسخه عن تويتر لا يبدو
مثل الباقين وعداده ينمو بعشره الملايين
مع مرور الساعات لدرجه ان اسمه باتا قاتل
تويتر
[تصفيق]
لكن القصه في عمقها تتعلق بالرجل الذي
اشترى تويتر طرد معظم موظفيه ووضع تعريفه
ماليه مقابل خدماته وكان هو تويتر من دون
ايلون ماسك
[موسيقى]
على كل حال ماسك اتهم ملكه وصانع فريز
مارك بالغش واذا كان هناك كلام فكاهي عن
مصارعه مباشره مرتقبه بين الرجلين فان
المصارعه على اشردها بين التغريد والتثريد
لصباح العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم بالارقام نتعرف على ابرز مكان في
اول ايام انطلاقه تطبيق من حيث المضمون
يمكن كتابه 500 مقابل 280
هي مده الفيديو التي يمكن تحميله على
فريدز مقابل دقيقتين وعشرين ثانيه في
تويتر مليون مشترك دخلوا في تطبيق خلال
ساعه واحده كاسرع تطبيق وصولا الى هذا
الرقم 100 دوله سيكون تطبيق فريدز متاحا
فيها خلال الفتره الاولى على ان يصل
للعالم كله قريبا
الحقيقه مشاهدينا عده تسريبات نالت حظ
الاسد من الانتشار مثلا تتريده نادي
مانشيستر يونايتد في وداع حارسه ديفيا
نالت اكثر من الف اعاده نشر فضلا ايضا عن
اكثر من 1500 اعجاب ايضا كان لاعب نادي
توتنهام الانجليزي البرازيلي اول المنضمين
الى حيث حققت تفريدته الاولى اكثر من 400
اعاده واكثر من 6000 اعجاب وكانت عباره عن
راس عصفور راس عصفور
ولا لي نشوي طيب مشاهدينا ايضا تتريده
مارك زوكربيرج الاولى التي رحب فيها
بالمنضمين لهذا التطبيق يا سمر اعلن عن
انطلاقه فيها حققت اكثر من 21,000 اعاده
وطبعا ما يزيد ايضا عن 180 الف اعجاب هذا
من اولها من اول يوم واول تفريده كذلك فان
تغريدته الاخرى حول ارتفاع عدد المنضمين
للفريدس الاكثر من 70 مليون حققت نحو 50
الف اعاده ونحو 300 الف اعجاب
ارقام قياسيه بالتاكيد
طيب ينضم الينا الان مشاهدينا من الرياض
فيصل السيف صانع المحتوى التقني اهلا
وسهلا فيك اذا يا فيصل معنا سمعنا يا فيصل
صباح الخير يا اهلا وسهلا وصباحكم الله
بالخير ان شاء الله
اهلا وسهلا طيب يا فيصل كثير من الكلام
واللغط واحنا لازم يكون مربوط بانستقرام
بتقدرش تحذفه الا مع يعني الا مع انستجرام
خبرنا الحقيقه هل فعلا مثلا كثير ناس
صاروا متخوفين منه الان لانه اذا قرروا
بدهم يحذفوا راح يطير حسابهم على
الانستقرام نفس الوقت
خلينا نبدا بهالنقة أنت ذكرتيها انه
بالفعل نعم تعطيه الحساب يعني تعطيل نوعا
ما حساب انستغرام ولكن التوضيح النهائي
صار في تحديث نفس القواني اللي موجوده
عليها بالامكان تعطيل حساب فريندز
والاستمرار باستخدام حساب انستجرام بدون
اي اثر ولكن حذف الحساب الاول يعني ح
الثاني حسب شروط القوانين اللي موجوده
واللي طلعنا عليها فبالتالي وعد وايضا
المطور وعد احد المطورين على التويتر على
تويتر على تويتر فوعد انه هذا الموضوع
حيتم تحديثه
صيانته ان شاء الله في التحديثات قادمه
بتقول تعطيل بتحكيه يعني
طيب فيصل ممكن تسوي لنا تمثيل او
ديموستريشن على الفرق بين تويتر والفريدس
او كلنا شو الفرق بيناتهم
اذا تكلمنا على
بالفعل كانه تويتر في بعض التحسينات ومع
عوده للزمن في تقريبا ست سبع سنين نتكلم
على انشاء ثلجات من الاحاديث من السؤال
والحصول على الردود من الناس بشكل مباشر
وايضا امكانيه نشر الفيديوهات في بلد
المطوله وايضا الصور ولكن الى الحين ما في
قدرات تويتر من ناحيه البث المباشر من
ناحيه البودكاست الصوتي او نقدر نقول
الخدمات الصوتيه وايضا من ناحيه الرسائل
المباشره بطريقتها واسلوبها وايضا
المكالمات الموعودين فيها من ناحيه
التويتر فاننا كاننا نتكلم على تطبيق مش
انه مو مطور لا هو متطور وكل شيء ولكن في
خصائص كثيره تم ازالتها من هذا التطبيق
فبالتالي تويتر له تشبع ضخم من ناحيه
المستخدمين فنوعا ماء حقه مو موجود اما
تطبيق مرتبط بشبكه فيها اكثر من مليار
مستخدم فبالتالي ق الحصول على المستخدمين
اكثر بكثير والنمو اكثر بكثير
ولكن مهم جدا يمكن هذا هو مربط الفرس فيصل
يعني فيما يخص التحديثات وكذا هذا شيء
دائما مستمر في اي تطبيق سواء كان في
بداياته او بعد ما يكون له عشره او 15 سنه
ولكن مربط الفرس في هذا الموضوع انه هل
فكره انه مطور من شركه مثل متى في الها
فيسبوك في الها انستجرام وهالقاعده قاعده
المتابعين والمشتركين الهائله هو اللي راح
يعطيه مفتاح النجاح ولا تصرفات
الهون ماسك هي اللي راح تنجح
تصرفات نجح قاعد يسويلها
تسويق وبالفعل هذا الامر قد يسبب في
انتشار التطبيق هل ينجح دائما شفنا خلال
15 سنه الماضيه مع السوشيال ميديا كل ما
كان في تطبيق ينسخ تطبيق ثاني اذا ما
اعطانا قيمه مضافه بهذا التطبيق ابدا ما
ينتشر ويطلع اذا ما جت منصه تواصل اجتماعي
يكون فيها توثيق جدا عالي فنعرف انه الامر
غالبا ما حيكون فيه نجاح وهيكون فيه زي
الهبه انتشار في البدايه ثم ذهب ونقطه
مهمه لازم نخليها في بالنا الى الحين
المنصه المعتمده من كثير من صناع القرار
من الدول من الجهات الرسميه في المملكه في
الامارات على تويتر فمهم وليله حيغيروا
القرض وحينتقلوا الى منصه ثانيه فهنا نعرف
هنا الموضوع مستخدمين نعم طب بما انه
نتكلم عن المستخدمين اريد اعرف منك فيصل
الان يعني من المتعارف عليه بصوره عامه
الديموغرافيه او العمر مثلا سناب شات
للشباب الاصغر شويه انستغرام للي بنوصل
الفيسبوك اصبح الان اكثر للاكبر عمرا يعني
مثلا
50 فما فوق او البيبي بومرز مثل ما يقولون
عليهم طب برايك من يستهدف كديموغرافيا
يعني
جميل جدا نفس جمهور انستجرام فانستجرام
حصلوا على نسخه خاصه فيها ونتكلم على
الشباب وهي نوعا ما نتكلم على وجهه نظري
والى منتصف العشرينات ليش اقول العمر هذا
كغالبيه المستخدمين لانه هم ايضا يشكلوا
غالبيه مستخدمين انستقرام ولما نلاحظ
الفردات وطريقه التايم لاين خط الزمني
الموجود على ملاحظه انه اكثر الصور
وفيديوهات وهنا نعرف انه ما سوى شيء
انتقلوا من انستجرام وراحوا هناك وبداوا
ينشروا الصور والميمز والحركات هذه اللي
هي اصلا طباعهم على نفس انستجرام تطبيق
يبغى لنا وقت لما نشوف انتشاره قبل ما
ننهي معك قبل ما ننهي معك عم بتقول بانه
الديموغرافيه هي ديموغرافيه مستخدمي
انستقرام طب معنى ذلك بان هم يعني
تويتر بسوقين مختلفين صعب انهم يتنافسوا
اصلا
مختلفين الى حد ما ونلاحظ انه الى الحين
ما زالت الامور ماشيه على تويتر ما صار
فيها انكماش من ناحيه المستخدمين وهي وطرح
التطبيق بربطه بانستجرام بشكل مباشر موضوع
تسويقي واستفاده من قواعد بيانات موجوده
افتحوا على اي حساب انستغرام الحين مع
التحديث اللي صار مؤخرا حتلاقوا مكتوب كم
رقمكم في انضمامكم على تسويقي فكل واحد
تحت اسم المستخدم قاعد يطلع له هالشيء
يبغى لنا للسوق
نتوقع اي تطبيق ينتشر ويصير في عنده كثافه
من المستخدمين بعد ميه مئتين مليون مستخدم
حيبدا نشوف سوق للاستفاده منه
دائما موجود مستحيل يروح شكرا فيصل السيف
صانع المحتوى التقني شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
يا فيصل لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات